POWER AND THEY ARE SITTING IN
THIS ROOM TONIGHT.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE, HIS
FIRST TELEVISION INTERVIEW SINCE
TAKING THE GAVEL, 55TH SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES,
KEVIN MCCARTHY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: HOW WAS YOUR WEEK LAST
WEEK?
>> IT WAS ENTERTAINING.
YOU KNOW, I THINK I BUILT A
LITTLE NAME I.D.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, WHAT'S
AMAZING ABOUT THIS TO ME, AND I
MAY BE WRONG, BUT TELL ME IF I'M
RIGHT.
I TALK TO A LOT OF MEMBERS.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
SOME OF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ON TV BUT YOU CAME BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO SUPPORT THE SPEAKER.
BUT I HAVE A FEELING THAT 222
PEOPLE AGREE ON JIM JORDAN'S
INVESTIGATION, AND THAT WOULD BE
INTO WHETHER THE FBI'S
POLITICIZED THE DOJ WEAPONIZED.
>> THEY WEAPONIZED.
HOMELAND, FBI.
WE'VE WATCHED THEM GET OUT OF
CONTROL WITH NO CHECK AND
BALANCE.
BUT LAST WEEK WAS TOUGH.
BUT REMEMBER WHAT MY FATHER
ALWAYS SAID.
IT'S NOT HOW YOU START, IT'S HOW
YOU FINISH.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER LAST WEEK.
OUR VERY FIRST BILL, WE REPEALED
87,000 IRS AGENTS.
>> Sean: YOU PROMISED TO DO IT.
>> WE PROMISED TO DO IT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE MADE OUR COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA, WHICH YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT.
>> Sean: I HAVE MY OWN COPY.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WE DID
NEXT?
WE JUST PASSED THE CHURCH STYLE
COMMITTEE THAT JIM JORDAN WILL
RUN LOOKING AT THE WEAPONIZATION
OF GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WE JUST PASSED
RIGHT NOW?
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CHINA.
WE GOT 146 DEMOCRATS TO VOTE
WITH US.
PELOSI WOULD NEVER ALLOW IT.
THEY HAD AN AGREEMENT WITH HER.
SHE BACKED AWAY THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
YOU WANT TO BRING JOBS BACK FROM
CHINA TO AMERICA.
YOU WANT TO STOP THEM FROM
BUYING OUR FARM LAND.
STEALING OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
THIS IS WHERE IT ALL STARTS.
THIS IS ONLY OUR FIRST COUPLE
DAYS IN POWER.
>> Sean: SO THE POWER OF THE
PURSE, WHICH WE'LL TALK ABOUT AT
LENGTH, THE POWER OF SUBPOENAS.
THOSE ARE THE TWO BIG POWERS YOU
HAVE.
OKAY.
LET'S FOCUS ON THE INVESTIGATION
PART.
JIM JORDAN, APPROPRIATIONS.
>> WE GOT JAMES COBURN.
HE'LL BE LOOKING INTO THE BIDEN
FAMILY SYNDICATE.
WE KNOW EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM
KNOWS ONE THING.
THAT JOE BIDEN LIED.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAID NOT ONE TIME
DID HE EVER TALK TO HIS SON
HUNTER ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
WE HAVE PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE
AND EVIDENCE OF MEETINGS THAT
HAVE TAKEN PLACE, AND WITNESSES
THAT WILL ATTEST TO SUCH.
>> GOT DOCUMENTS THEY DENIED US.
DO YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT, 40
YEARS OF BEING ELECTED, WHY DO
YOU THINK HE WENT TO THE BORDER?
BECAUSE WE WERE SWORN IN.
HE KNOWS WHAT'S COMING.
YOU'VE GOT TO SECURE YOUR
BORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO USE EVERY POWER
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT
THIS COUNTRY AND LOOK OUT FOR
THE AMERICAN TAXPAYER.
>> Sean: I THINK LAST WEEK, AT
LEAST PART OF IT, WAS
REPUBLICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WERE DISAPPOINTED IN PAST
SPEAKERS.
JOHN BOEHNER.
I WAS DISAPPOINTED IN JOHN
BOEHNER.
I THINK THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE
THAT WANTED THE ASSURANCES.
I HAD INTERVIEWED YOU ENOUGH.
I HAD ASKED YOU REPEATEDLY THE
COMMITMENTS TO AMERICA.
I HAVE MY VERSION RIGHT HERE,
WHICH WE'LL TALK ABOUT.
THEY WANTED TO KNOW THESE
INVESTIGATIONS WERE REAL.
WHAT OTHER INVESTIGATION?
>> YOU'VE GOT TO HOLD GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THE WHOLE TIME DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN IN POWER, ALL THEY'VE
DONE IS INCREASED SPENDING.
WHY DON'T WE HAVE A CHECK AND
BALANCE?
THINK OF THIS.
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS WERE IN
POWER LAST TIME FOR EIGHT YEARS,
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING INCREASED
IN THOSE YEARS?
ZERO.
THEY WERE IN POWER FOUR YEARS.
THEY INCREASED IT BY 30%.
IT WENT FROM SPENDING $4
TRILLION TO $7 TRILLION.
THEY'VE CREATED INFLATION.
WE'VE GOT TO GET OUR COUNTRY
UNDER CONTROL FINANCIALLY.
HOW DO WE DO THAT?
ENERGY POLICY.
THEY MADE THE PRICE OF GAS GO UP
BUT MADE US WEAK AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE WILL BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
OUR BORDER'S NOT SECURE.
BUT LOOK WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO
OUR SCHOOLS AS WELL.
RIGHT?
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A PARENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS.
ALSO, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
AS WELL, WHEN WE LOOK AT CHECKS
AND BALANCES, YOU GOT COMER, JIM
JORDAN.
EVERY SINGLE COMMITTEE HAS AN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
SO EVERY DOLLAR MATTERS, HOW WE
SPEND IT, AND WE'LL BE LOOKING
AT EVERYTHING.
NO MORE BLANK CHECKS.
>> Sean: YOU WILL VOTE ON EVERY
APPROPRIATIONS BILL
INDEPENDENTLY, ALL 12 OF THEM.
>> YES.
>> Sean: WE'LL GET TO THAT.
WHAT OTHER INVESTIGATIONS?
COVID?
>> WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHERE COVID
STARTED?
THEY WON'T HAVE ANY HEARINGS ON
IT.
WHY SHOULDN'T WE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN THOSE
LAST TWO MONTHS?
13 GOLD STAR FAMILIES HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THIS
NATION HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW SO IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
WE SHOULD KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH CHINA AND WHERE THE MONEY
IS GOING.
WE KNOW THE DOCUMENTS ARE THERE.
I THINK THE COUNTRY HAS A RIGHT
TO KNOW THAT AS WELL.
BUT THE WEAPONIZATION OF WHAT
THE FBI --
>> Sean: FAUCI?
>> THAT GOES RIGHT INTO COVID.
WE HAVE OUR OWN ABILITY TO
OVERSEE THAT AND LOOK INTO IT.
>> Sean: I HAVE QUESTIONS
WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS HONEST.
WHAT DID HE KNOW?
DID OUR TAX DOLLARS TO THE NIH,
WAS IT FUNNELED THROUGH THE ECO
ALLIANCE, WHATEVER THE GROUP WAS
CALLED.
WERE WE GIVING MONEY TO THE
WUHON LAB OF VIROLOGY WHERE THEY
KNEW GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
TOOK PLACE, WHERE THEY KNEW
CORONAVIRUS RESEARCH TOOK PLACE?
SO WE HAVE THAT INVESTIGATION.
THE AFGHANISTAN INVESTIGATION.
FBI, DOJ.
THE BIDEN FAMILY INVESTIGATION.
NOW LET'S GET TO THE ISSUE OF
FINANCES AND MONEY AND SPENDING.
WHY DON'T YOU EXPLAIN HOW THIS
PROCESS NOW WILL BE DIFFERENT.
WE'RE COMING UP AGAINST THE DEBT
CEILING VOTE AND WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO MEAN.
THAT MIGHT BE THE FIRST TEST OF
HOW COMMITTED THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN THE HOUSE IS TO REALLY
HOLDING THE LINE ON SPENDING.
AM I WRONG ON THAT?
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT WRONG ON THAT.
THINK FOR ONE MOMENT.
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREATS WE
HAVE TO OUR NATION IS OUR DEBT.
IT MAKES US WEAK IN EVERY PLACE
THAT WE CAN.
WE HAVE NEVER BEEN AT THIS HIGH
OF DEBT AND GDP EXCEPT DURING
WORLD WAR II.
WHAT ARE WE FUNDING?
WASTEFUL WASHINGTON SPENDING
MUCH OF THE TIME.
SO WE THINK IF YOU HAD A CHILD
AND YOU GAVE HIM A CREDIT CARD
AND THEY KEPT HITTING THE LIMIT.
DO YOU JUST INCREASE THE LIMB OR
DO YOU CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR?
THIS IS OUR MOMENT TO CHANGE THE
BEHAVIOR TO MAKE SURE
HARDWORKING TAXPAYER, THAT WE'RE
NOT WASTING THEIR MONEY.
YOU GONNA TELL ME THERE'S NOT
WASTE OUT THERE?
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE
DOLLAR SPENT.
WE'RE GOING TO AUDIT IT.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE WE
BALANCE OUR BUDGET, MAKE US
STRONGER.
>> Sean: YEARS AGO CONNIE MACK
FROM FLORIDA.
WE PROBABLY NEED THE $0.25 PLAN
BECAUSE THE DEBT HAS GONE UP SO
SIGNIFICANTLY.
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'D THINK
ABOUT?
>> WE THINK ABOUT A LOT.
THIS IS PART OF THE DISCUSSION
LAST WEEK.
IT WAS HEALTHY AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
WE'RE STRONGER TODAY TO HAVE
GONE THROUGH IT.
>> Sean: I WISH YOU WOULD HAVE
DONE IT BEFORE JANUARY 3RD.
>> WE TRIED.
>> Sean: TALKING TO A LOT OF
YOUR FRIENDS, SOME OF THEM IN
THIS ROOM BUT I WON'T GIVE THEM
UP.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY
EVERYONE FOUND WE HAD AN
AGREEMENT.
THAT'S WHAT OUR RULES PACKAGE
DOES.
WE ALSO WANTED TO PROTECT
OURSELVES FROM THE SENATE.
THEY WON'T DO THEIR WORK.
THEY WON'T PASS ANY
APPROPRIATION BILL.
THEN THEY TRY TO JAM US RIGHT
BEFORE CHRISTMAS WITH $1.7
TRILLION.
I WENT OVER THE SENATE TO THEIR
LUNCH AND SAID, WE'LL NEVER TAKE
UP AN OMNI AGAIN.
YOU HAVE TO PASS YOUR
APPROPRIATIONS BILLS
INDIVIDUALLY.
JUST THE WAY CONGRESS IS
SUPPOSED TO WORK.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, WHAT THEY
DID IN THE SENATE, I BELIEVE AS
A CONSERVATIVE, THAT WAS A
DISGRACE.
THEY KNEW YOU WERE COMING INTO
POWER.
>> WHY WOULDN'T THEY JUST WAIT?
IF THEY WAITED, WE'D HAVE A
STRONGER HAND.
WE WOULDN'T BE INCREASING IT.
THEY INCREASED THE BASELINE
WHERE IT JUST ADDS SO MUCH MORE
TO OUR CHILDREN.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT A
MOMENT.
MAYBE IT COMES SOONER, MAYBE IT
COMES LATER, ON THE DEBT
CEILING.
YOU KNOW HOW THE ARGUMENTS WILL
UNFOLD.
IT WILL BE REPUBLICANS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN GOVERNMENT.
I HAVE BEEN AROUND THIS GAME TOO
LONG.
GOVERNMENT NEVER SHUTS DOWN.
ESSENTIAL SERVICES WILL EXIST.
GRANDMA, MOM AND DAD, THEY'RE
GONNA GET THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY
CHECK.
MEDICARE'S NOT GONNA BE SHUT
DOWN.
THE MILITARY'S NOT GONNA BE SHUT
THERE MIGHT BE PEOPLE THAT GET
FURLOUGHED BUT ODDS ARE PRETTY
HIGH WHEN THEY GET THEIR FREE
VACATION, THEY WILL GET BACK
PAY.
BUT THAT WILL BE THE ARGUMENT.
NOW THE QUESTION WILL BECOME A
GAME OF CHICKEN.
THAT IS, REPUBLICANS ARE
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT AND
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO RAISE THE
DEBT CEILING.
YOU'RE GONNA SAY WHAT?
>> WELL, LISTEN.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO COME TO THAT.
I HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN TO THE
PRESIDENT.
LET'S SIT DOWN NOW.
LET'S FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN
BOTH COME TOGETHER TO ACTUALLY
CURB THE RISING DEBT THAT WE
HAVE.
>> Sean: YOU TALKED TO JOE
BIDEN?
>> HE CALLED ME THE OTHER DAY.
>> Sean: DID HE KNOW WHO YOU
WERE?
>> HE DID AT THAT MOMENT.
>> Sean: OUCH.
COME ON, THAT'S FUNNY.
YOU'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
I SAY.
>> WE'LL WORK WITH ANYBODY.
WE'RE ALL FOR ONE BRANCH HERE.
WE CONTROL CONGRESS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE HAVE FUNDING POWERS.
WE WANT TO UTILIZE IT TO
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WE DON'T WANT TO PUT US IN ANY
JEOPARDY, BUT WE DON'T WANT TO
JUST HAVE THIS RUN AWAY
SPENDING.
INCREASING 30% IN FOUR YEARS.
>> Sean: HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU
HAVE BEFORE THIS DEBT CEILING?
>> WE HAVE PROBABLY UNTIL
SUMMERTIME.
>> Sean: PLENTY OF TIME.
>> WE'RE WORKING ON IT NOW.
WE'RE SETTING THE PLAN TO
ACTUALLY PUT IT ON TO A PATH TO
BALANCE.
THAT'S WHAT OUR DISCUSSIONS WERE
ALL ABOUT.
>> Sean: WHAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP
NOW LIKE WITH THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE SENATE?
YOU WERE BEGGING THEM NOT TO DO
WITH OMNI BUS, GO ON WITH A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION INSTEAD.
THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
THEY HAD THE BEST OPPORTUNITY.
SO HOW --
>> I WANT TO EMPOWER THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE.
UTILIZE US.
SCHUMER RUNS THE SENATE, BUT
IT'S A CLOSE MAJORITY.
BUT WHY DON'T THEY WORK WITH US?
I'M SETTING UP EVERY COMMITTEE
CHAIR TO WORK WITH THE RANKING
REPUBLICAN THERE.
LET'S TALK WITH OUR BILLS.
LET'S TAKE THEIR AMENDMENTS, PUT
THEM INTO OURS AND MOVE THEM
OVER THERE TO EMPOWER THEM TO BE
STRONGER.
IF I SAID, I TOLD SCHUMER DO NOT
SEND AN OMNI BUS HERE.
IF YOU DON'T PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS BILL, WE AREN'T
TAKING IT UP.
WE'LL PASS OUR APPROPRIATIONS
BILL AND THEN SEND THE
CONTINUING RESOLUTION.
WE'RE NOT SHUTTING DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
WE ARE DOING OUR WORK.
WE'RE ALSO PUTTING A LITTLE CUT
ON THERE LIKE THE PENNY PLAN.
>> Sean: USING THE POWER THAT
WAS GIVEN TO YOU BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> EXACTLY.
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: AND ONE OF YOUR
COMMITMENTS.
>> IN THE ELECTION - REPUBLICAN
THAT'S STRONG, A NATION THAT'S
SAFE, A FUTURE THAT'S BUILT ON
FREEDOM AND A GOVERNMENT THAT'S
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE STORY
ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE RAID AT MAR
A-LAGO.
ESPECIALLY AFTER HILLARY
CLINTON, DO YOU REMEMBER THE
JULY 2016 PRESS CONFERENCE JIM
COMEY, NO REASONABLE PROSECUTOR
WOULD EVER PROSECUTE, WAY MORE
TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
NEVER MIND THE DELETED E-MAILS
AND DESTROYED DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS AND THE REMOVAL OF SIM
CARDS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN NOW, IN
TERMS OF ALL THOSE DEMOCRATS WHO
WANTED DONALD TRUMP ARRESTED
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY?
>> THEY HAVE TO EAT THEIR WORDS.
THEY'VE GOTTEN AWAY WITH SO MUCH
FOR SO LONG.
THIS WAS DISCOVERED BEFORE THE
LAST ELECTION.
JUST LIKE THE LAP TOP.
THEY THINK THEY CAN CONTROL THE
MEDIA, LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC, SHUT DOWN IF ONE MEDIA
COMPANY WRITES ABOUT IT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE ABOVE THE
LAW.
WHY WEREN'T THEY RAIDED?
WHY DIDN'T HE IN "60 MINUTES"
SAY, I UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE I
BET I HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM.
DID BARACK OBAMA HAVE SOME OF
THIS WHEN HE WAS WRITING HIS
BOOK?
DID HILLARY CLINTON?
ALL THOSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN
GOVERNMENT FOR YEARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST RAN FOR
PRESIDENT.
DO YOU THINK HE MOVED HIS OWN
BOXES?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WERE LOCKED AWAY.
BIDEN'S WERE NOT.
HOW MANY YEARS AFTER DID HE HAVE
THOSE?
THE FBI WENT TO MAR A-LAGO.
THEY ASKED FOR A PADLOCK.
THE PADLOCK REQUEST WAS GRANTED.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN A RAID.
>> THEY THINK THE LAW DOESN'T
APPLY TO THEM.
THEY THINK THEY WRITE THEIR OWN
LAWS.
THAT'S WHAT INFURIATES THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
AMERICA BELIEVES IN FAIRNESS AND
HONESTY AND THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE GETTING.
>> Sean: WE ARE JUST GETTING
THINGS STARTED.
ON THAT NOTE, WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH SPEAKER MCCARTHY.
HE'LL STAY WITH US.
WE'LL CHECK WITH HOUSE MAJORITY
LEADER STEVE SCALISE.
ONE OF THE BIG INVESTIGATIONS
WILL BE JAMES COMBER AND JIM
JORDAN.
WE'RE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE'RE IN THE SWAMP.
WE'RE ONLY HERE FOR 24 HOURS OR
LESS.
WE'LL BE BACK IN JUST A SHORT
TIME.
STAY WITH US.